As you can see, I'm locked down in a room that's full of books,
and I know what most of them are.
But a few weeks ago I discovered the book I didn't realize I
had. And there was something really, quite exciting about it.
I found this book,
which is called introduction to chemical philosophy,
found it quite late at night.
And then I looked inside a much to my surprise.
I found signature that appeared to be from earnest
rather for the famous physicist. I was amazed.
Usually when you find these things, there's some sorts of forgery or joke,
but I was really excited photograph that incentive to
Keith Moore,
the hero of Brady's objectivity channel.
Who's an expert on things like this. And he emailed back and said,
he thought it was genuine.
Where did this book come from? Professor? How come you've got it?
I have two theories where it might have come from. I certainly didn't by myself.
And one theory is that I may have inherited it from my
friend David Jones,
who left me his whole library of books.
And I just selected a few in a big hurry.
And I probably chose this one because it's by Tilden.
Who's quite a famous 19th century chemist by probably just took it without
looking inside. The other possibility is that it was
inherited from my wife's family because her grandfather was
a student with Rutherford.
And I suppose it's possible that rather thought this is no book.
I don't know what to do with it. I'll give it to one of my students.
Professor from the signature to peers that he's written his name to say,
I own this book. He's not autographing it for us.
I totally agree. This is not a dedication to somebody.
This is a thing to show you own it. When I got the book out.
So we could make this video. I noticed surprisingly,
there is a second signature of a Rutherford
inside the cover where you can barely read it. No,
this book was published in 1886 when [inaudible] was 15.
And my theory is that perhaps he bought it second hand.
When he came as a student to England,
he was born in New Zealand because there are a couple of prices written in
pencil,
which is the signature of a second-hand book dealer.
And probably he wrote his name on the inside cover and thought nobody will
see it there. So he wrote it on the next page as well.
Perhaps we should tell people who earned us rather foot was. And secondly,
is that book worth a of money earned.
This Rutherford was the famous physicist who
formulated the first plausible structure of the atom
and discovered that alpha particles were the nuclei of helium
atoms. He won the Nobel prize for chemistry in two,
1908 and 11 of his students also won
Nobel prizes shows, have little, all of us have achieved.
I don't think the work is worth very much at all though. Keith Moore,
when he saw the signature and the fact that the book is also written by a fellow
of the Royal society is keen to have it from the library of
the Royal society. When I've got fed up with it.
Hang on a second. I might make you an offer. I'd quite like that one.
Maybe we should have a bidding war.
Other thing which I think is interesting is that this book contains a
really quite old periodic table.
This periodic table is therefore by fellow the oldest periodic table that I
possess. And if you look at it,
there are all sorts of strange things it's covered in question marks where
they might be new elements.
Of course they know noble gases because they hadn't been discovered,
but beryllium is certain with the G because
sometimes in those days,
people called it blue Sydney from the Greek word, meaning sweet,
but really am salts are really poisonous,
but somehow people tasted it and decided it tasted sweet.
And then boron,
which I've never seen before is written as BDO and rhodium as
aro.
I suspect they put the periodic table in into terrific hurry.
And they made some mistakes.
Professor just while you were talking. I w I,
I was doing a bit of Googling and I found an autograph letter signed by
Rutherford from 1920, selling for two and a half thousand dollars.
My feeling is that when it's a letter,
that's something really special when it's just
labeling a book,
just like he might have labeled his clothes for the laundry,
then it probably isn't quite as exciting.
But it's a book that's got the periodic table in it. And as we all know,
rather Fred's name is on the periodic table.
Yes, there wasn't then of course, no,
but I think I have no idea whether it's worth much money
and,
but it's a very nice feeling that I may be reading a book that
rather for great. Yeah.
Isn't it a great thought as well to think about Rutherford having a book and
looking at that periodic table,
not knowing that one day his name would be on it.
Yes, of course. That's the,
you assume the T actually read the book
and, um,
and the periodic table seems to be just added as an extra chapter.
The end. Are you going to give the book to Keith at the Royal society?
Probably eventually it could end up on objectivity in a second video,
but the other thing which is quite, I think is interesting.
There are a whole series of questions about the periodic table,
and I can't answer most of them.
They're so old fashioned questions like to explain
the differences between sodium and potassium.
And I have no idea what in 1880s,
somebody would have expected for announce of that question since then no answers
in the book. We'll never know.
Through the very moment when you first opened it and saw each other.
I was in my, in the study just about to go to bed.
So it was after 11 o'clock at night.
And for some reason I was just looking at the books and I opened this and I
thought, wow. But of course,
my first thought was the tea was appropriately a forgery,
or what type of though,
I don't see why anybody should put rather fits the name in a slightly up-skill
chemistry textbook. If you're going to forge it,
you would forge it somewhere else.
I also found in another room here,
this book here,
which has a photo of Rutherford with his signature, I mean,
this is a printed signature.
What's interesting is by the time he got the signature,
he'd become a Lord.
So he wrote to Rutherford without a knee because there's a
convention in the UK that people who are Lords,
then all men who loads signed just that title Rutherford,
because he was Lord Rutherford without a first name.
Thanks for watching. If you enjoyed this video,
I think there's a really good chance.
You'll enjoy my other YouTube channel objectivity.
It's all about all sorts of famous science,
objects and little stories from history.
I'll put a link here on the screen and down in the video description,
we are joined by captain disillusion. And guess what?
Today it's happening because this is where they store most of the moon rocks
and soil that will brought back from the moon by the Apollo astronauts joined by
Diana Cowan from the physics scale YouTube channel.
It's the white gloves of destiny.
I didn't tell you who was operating the camera cause it's not James James who
normally does that. He's back in the UK.
It's a very special celebrity camera operator actually.